thank you so much for joining us today
my name is Sarah one I'm the senior
director of translational science here
at nano string technologies and I'm
pleased to be talking with you today
about some recent work that we've been
doing at nano string and specifically
I'm going to be focusing on two papers
that we've just been publishing they use
our G omics
platform to understand the role of
b-cells in response to immuno therapy
and I'm very pleased to be with you
today I'm a immunologist by training and
so I'm very interested in understanding
how cellular immune responses are
shaping the tumor micro-environment
and the progression of cancer and
specifically it is it has become obvious
in the field recently that the there are
structures called tertiary lymphoid
organs that arise within tumors that are
very important for shaping that immune
response so tertiaries employed
structures are atopic lymphoid organs
which means that they arise in places
where there's not normally lymph tissue
and they occur in places where there is
chronic inflammation ongoing and what it
is is is that it is an immune organ that
actually formed and organizes itself
into regions of T cells and B cells and
follicular dendritic cells that all come
together and interact and promote immune
response and then that immune response
can help to propagate and shape an
immune response within the tumor
microenvironment and directed against
tumor antigens so specifically within
these tertiary lymphoid structures as
you can see on the slide here there are
many different cell types that are
involved they are very structurally
organized and the consequences of
activity within the tertiaries of what
structures RTLS is is that we see
increased levels of T cell
differentiation and T cell maturation
into effector memory and effector cells
so SCI
toxic T cells memory b-cells plasma
cells that are generating antibodies and
these can then impact those immune
responses against the tumor
so there's been a lot of investigation
over the past few years about really
what is the impact of these tertiary
lymphoid structures on the prognosis of
tumors and many studies have been done
to understand if they have a prognostic
effect and the results have been mixed
but generally suggesting that yes having
triggers employed structures is positive
for a disease prognosis disease outcome
good outcomes for these patients I'm
showing here just three examples from
colorectal cancer non-small-cell lung
cancer and pancreatic cancer that all
suggest that having tertiary lymphoid
structures increases the rates of
disease-free survival but the role of
TLS is in melanoma is less clear right
it's um there have been mixed reports
about their clinical impact and at a
molecular and cellular level
understanding what effects they're
having on the immune response to
melanoma um our studies that had not
been done previously
so recently two groups undertook an
effort to answer some of these questions
and really try to characterize the
impact of the TL s's within the context
of melanoma and these papers were
published in a very recent issue of the
journal Nature and you can see on the
left side of the slide one of these
papers came from the University of lund
in Sweden and the other paper came from
MD Anderson Cancer Center in Houston and
so these were studies that were done
independently and each took a
multi-platform approach to really
dissecting the role of the tls in
melanoma and you can see on the right
slide I've Illustrated just some of the
technologies that were employed in this
characterization and the one we're going
to be focusing on today is in the upper
right hand corner called DSP digital
profiling what is the SP dissy is a
platform that was invented at nano
string and is now commercially available
so it is a system that we call the geo
mix platform and it is an instrument
which enables spatially resolved
molecular characterization of tissue
samples using sspe as a starting
material and what it does is it images
the tissue and it also performs
molecular profiling from regions of
interest within that tissue to allow you
to do very high plex analyses of the
distribution of proteins and RNAs within
that sample so in a bit more detail here
is what the features of that system look
like we use a series of detection
reagents which are either all ago
labeled antibodies or RNA binding
moieties which have indexing ala goes on
them separated with a photo cleavable
linker and that linker becomes very
important when we take those detection
reagents and we put them on to an FFPE
slide and then we can image the slide
using immunofluorescent markers and
select regions of interest that we want
to profile and these regions of interest
can be as large as 600 microns where or
it can be as small as a single
lymphocyte and once we've selected those
regions of interest we shine UV light
just in that area and that please that
linker releases those ala goes and then
allows us to collect and quantitate
those ala goes using either our
encounter platform or next-generation
sequencing technology so what we get at
the end of the day is both a digital
picture of the of the slide using for
color immunofluorescence and that you
can see in the upper right hand side of
this slide and also molecular data about
the specific regions of interest that
you have chosen to profile that allows
you to do high flex characterization of
the proteins or the RNAs and what's
really fantastic about this technology
is that it's we have a lot of
flexibility over the size
the shape of these regions of interests
that we're going to be profiling and
that's really useful because we know
that tissue heterogeneity is really
driven by underlying interactions
between cells within a specific region
and so as we have tumor cells
interfacing with stromal cells or immune
cells in a tumor micro-environment
we want to optically dissect those two
compartments and we can do that using
the geo mix platform and by controlling
the shape of that UV light we can
separate and profile those two cell
types separately I'm not going to go
into the details of the technology but I
would encourage you to come to the nano
string website to learn more about how
it works or to reach out to your Nana
string representatives who would be
happy to provide you with additional
information but we have built this
platform and we've also been been able
to build a library of detection reagents
that allow you to profile the targets
that are of greatest interest for doing
immuno oncology research so on the left
side of this slide you can see that we
have a protein profiling library that is
customizable because there's a central
core of targets that you're going to be
profiling and then you add on modules as
you need to address the biology that you
are specifically interested in and
there's also the possibility of adding
custom proteins at the same time so if
you have antibodies against a specific
target we can we can add labels to those
and then you can collect that data
alongside all of the other data and
antibodies that we've already validated
today we have over 60 antibodies that
have been labeled and validated in our
process they can all be used
simultaneously on a single tissue slide
and they are really focused on being
able to profile holistically that that
immune response
when we move over to the RNA side we
have even more options here because now
we don't have to rely on having
available antibodies which as you know
is not always an easy thing to develop
but here we have a panel that's called
our cancer transcriptome atlas and this
is really contains the vast majority of
genes that are necessary to characterize
tumor immune interactions it contains
all of the the best targets from our
most popular encounter panels including
IO 360 and cancer pathways pen cancer
immune as well as additional targets
that we have come to appreciate our
important in regulating that those tumor
immune interactions so in total there
are more than 1,800 characterized genes
that are in this panel and we can
collect molecular data about all of
these targets again with a single
experiment with a single tissue slide
and so we've seen a lot of success with
this technology and our customers and
our collaborators are also having a lot
of success using geo mix to uncover
fundamental high-impact
facets of immuno oncology biology and
we've had a lot of success publishing
here you can see some of the 13
publications that have been generated to
date appearing in very high profiled
journals like clinical cancer research
cancer research nature medicine as well
as the journal Nature and now I'm really
going to be telling you the story today
of three of those publications and the
first that we're going to start with was
actually the first G omics paper that
was published and this was a paper that
came from MD Anderson from the
laboratory of dr. Jennifer Varga and it
appeared in nature medicine in 2018 and
in this study her group was looking to
characterize the immune response that
was elicited by neoadjuvant and adjuvant
immunotherapy in patients with stage
three melanoma and she was again taking
a multi-platform approach to
characterize all of the
immunological changes that were induced
in response to treatment and also to
understand which of those were
associated with favorable outcome and
what she observed from that paper from
doing the genomeics profiling here was
that there was an increased abundance of
proteins that were associated with B
cells that were observed in patients
that had favorable outcomes so you can
see using two different antibodies from
a single experiment we got independent
validation that both cd19 and cd20 which
are key molecules expressed exclusively
on B cells were expressed at higher
levels in patients with good response
and this was exciting and intriguing
results because as I mentioned before
the role of B cells in regulating tumor
immune interactions has not been fully
elucidated
so she wanted to go on and dissect this
role of the b-cells in greater detail
and to do that she turned to a different
clinical trial that she had samples
available from where again we were
looking at patients with advanced
melanoma and this time giving them
immunotherapy as a neoadjuvant prior to
surgery and we're very fortunate that
this is the result that was published in
January of this year
in the Journal of Nature and so what she
was doing with the geo mix profiling
specifically was to look at FFPE tissue
sections from the melanoma patient from
the pretreatment biopsies and focusing
specifically on the tertiary lymphoid
structures and so in this slide you can
see that I've highlighted the slide
images from just one patient and we've
got the immunofluorescent images that
were collected on G omics on the left
and then the corresponding HD image on
the right and we've highlighted the
tumor the TLS is for you here and within
those TLS 'as we were then dissecting
out optically using the that UV light to
characterize t-cells and b-cells
separately and what we observed here was
that in the t-cell compartment for
t-cells that were in the TLS they had
higher expression of the activation
markers and of checkpoint molecules than
did t-cells that were located externally
to TLS so this is suggesting that as I
described to you at the beginning that
actually yes the the presence of T cells
and these TLS is is promoting their
maturation is promoting their
differentiation and the graphs that
we're looking at on the left here is
showing you the aggregate results from
each of the individual patients that we
profile and on the right side of the
slide you can see for each of the
individual patients you know how their
expression of these particular markers
was varying and so there's quite a quite
a heterogeneity between the patients and
some overall tren
for the most robust genes that were
observed across all the patients and the
other thing that we've done that's not
represented on this slide but is
certainly something that is possible
with the geo mix profiling is to then
look within each of the patient
individual samples and look at the
distribution of protein expression
within the different TL essence or
within those different regions of
interest that we profile to add another
layer of complexity and variability in
the data and even more finely dissect
the molecular expression patterning that
is controlling those immune responses
you
um and when she looked in a greater
detail here at the level of TL s's at
the level of the b-cells specifically
she was able to to identify that b-cells
were associated with proliferation as
indicated by ki67 and that we were
seeing in some patients differences in
that that level of b-cell activation in
the TL the TL s's which also suggests
then that not only are the t-cells
becoming activated but the B cells
themselves are becoming activated
developing into memory b-cells
developing into potentially those plasma
b-cells that could be secreting
anti-tumor antibodies to further mediate
the tumor immune responses
and the results that she generated on G
omics were also supported by other
profiling characterization that she did
on the samples so I'm not going to go
into great detail but again I just
wanted to show you very briefly that the
RNA seek data that she generated also
suggested that there were higher
expression of B cell associated genes in
the PLSS
as well as immunofluorescence and
immunohistochemistry staining that
corroborated the role of TLS and B cells
and T cell activation happening here in
the context of the TLS in the tumor
micro-environment
the second paper then that was published
in the same issue of nature's back to
back article is the paper that came from
one University from the laboratory of
Professor Lauren Johnson and dr. Johnson
had available to him tissue microarrays
of biopsies from melanoma patients and
some of those biopsies contained
tertiary lymphoid structures so we
wanted to use the geo mix platform to
characterize the tls is here and the non
TLS tissue as well so that we could
understand whether the same trends that
were observed in in dr. mordough studies
could also be seen in these studies and
so the profiling strategy here was
similar we had two different TMA's to
profile a fraction of them had TLS in
them here we used a masking strategy
that allowed us to optically dissect out
the protein expression patterns from t
cells from the tumor cells and from
b-cells separately and so you can see
the masking that we did here based on
each of those ROI selection strategies
and that allows us to again very finely
discriminate where the the protein
signaling is coming from and this is not
not a level of dissection that that's
really available on any other
profiling platform
so dr. Johnson observed when he looked
at the B cell signatures that there were
two different populations of B cells
that were present within these tissue
samples and they were really separated
based on their level of p67
and so this suggested to him that there
are T CTLs is there at different states
of maturation where as the tls is formed
the B cells are more quiet and then as
they go on to develop and mature and
form more of a architectural structure
the B cells become activated and then
are potentially able to have more impact
on regulating the T cell activation and
as a data that supported the hypotheses
around B cells regulating T cell
activation is what's shown on the right
side of the graph here where when he
looked at the T cell areas of interest
that were from T cells that were close
to the T close to her within the TLS is
versus those that were very far away
from the TL s's he observed that there
was more expression of cd4 and more
expression of the anti-apoptotic protein
bcl-2 when the T cells were located
within those t LSE's so this is
suggesting that if they've become
activated that they are differentiating
that they are seeing more exposure to
the antigen and may becoming more
activated to mediate a stronger
anti-tumor immune response
he also was able to look at the level of
the the t-cells specifically in greater
detail here so you're seeing now not
just those those three targets but we're
looking here also at T LSE's from a
t-cells from tumors that had no tlf
presences within them T cells from
tumors with TLS and she cells from
tumors out within the TLS themselves and
we're seeing here again different
molecular patterns different patterns of
expression of these of these targets
that is suggesting that these T cells
are existing within different states and
you can see that indicated more clearly
for the individual cores that were on
the T MA in the box and whisker plots
that are on the right so those T cells
that are that are inside the TL s's tend
to have different patterns of expression
of the activation markers in the immune
checkpoint markers themselves
and then he went on as well to
characterize the melanocytes and the
actual tumor cells that could be
regulating also the activation and
activity of the T cells once they've
left the tls s and here what you can see
on the left is that he's looking at
again the different molecular patterns
that are expressed by the melanocytes
from tumors with or without T LSE's or
the people employed aggregates and what
you can see is that there are very
different patterns there are the
canonical cold tumors in the middle
indicated in the yellow bucket where
there's very little expression of
activation molecules or antigen
expression molecules by the UM by the
tumor cells themselves he then was able
to look at B to M copy number and see
that there was increased presence of
loss of B to M in that particular sample
population compared to looking at tumors
that had T cells or tumors that had the
TL s's so this is really suggesting that
that there is biology that is being
regulated by the tls and that is
promoting anti-tumor immune response and
it's also indicating that you know all
of this was dot was data that was
collected on the geo mix platform so
this is a platform that is very useful
for dissecting out those underlying
biology z' and revealing a great deal of
the complexity of tumors in a way that
is requiring a very little amount of
tissue and is very tissue sparing so all
of the data that i'm i have shown you
here was collected from a single slide
from each patient and so it's really a
very large amount of data that is is
being generated from a very small amount
of clinical tissue which is very helpful
when you're often working with a small
amounts of patient tissue and it's
difficult to characterize by any
molecular signals in great detail
so I hope that I have shown you today
that the Gio makes platform can be used
for spatially resolving the RNA and
protein profiles from the tumor
micro-environment and that it can be
used then to reveal biology that would
be otherwise invisible if both profiling
is all that's performed on the tissue
I hope you've also seen that geo mix
experiment can translate very well
across labs so there is very little user
to user variability site to site
variability and so it generates very
highly important results if the
underlying biology that's measured is
similar which really enables a cross lab
collaboration comparison of different
datasets to quickly drill down in on
that biology which's which is ground
truth which is most most impactful then
for regulating regulating tumour immune
responses and I hope you've also come to
appreciate that incorporating spatial
profiling into your translational
research has the potential to lead to
the development of more predictive
biomarkers that may someday be able to
you be used to improve patient outcomes
to immunotherapy by allowing us to
target those patients which are going to
be most sensitive to any given I Oh
therapeutics and our hope is that the
geo mix platform and in combination with
profiling on other other platforms such
as our end counter for both tissue
profiling leads to a cycle of continuous
discoveries that is going to accelerate
the pace at which we are able to learn
about the underlying biology of tumor
immune interactions identify new drug
candidate develop and test those drug
candidates very quickly and then develop
the biomarkers associated with them that
will allow us to give those therapies to
the appropriate patient population so I
thank you for your time in listening
with us today
I would encourage you to visit our
website of Geo mix at nano string comm
to learn more information about the
genomics spacial profiler and we'd be
happy to answer any questions that are
submitted through the email alias that's
going to be presented in conjunction
with this webinar thank you very much
have a great day bye
you